well for profit beat estimates in the
fourth quarter hard get too excited
though since net income fell to just a
penny a share a slender sent but CEO
mark field says pre-tax profit could
grow by more than fifty percent this
year Matt Miller is standing by right
now with the chief financial officer of
the Ford Motor Company Bob shanks Matt
it's all yours alright thanks very much
Eric yeah we're looking at a pre-tax
profit forecast of a boost of eight to
nine percent for 2015 Bob you are
optimistic and I'm assuming that's
because you're getting finished with
changeovers like that to the new f-150
and you're now able to start selling
these new higher margin vehicles
absolutely man and it's good to see you
again that's exactly what we talked
about all through 2014 that it was going
to be a setup year for very strong
growth in 2015 and f-150 was a very
important part of that the launch in
Dearborn has gone extremely well we've
added the third crew the launch in
Kansas City is progressing very well and
by the time we get to the second quarter
we'll have the whole f-150 system up and
running so very very strong results so
far in the marketplace products moving
very quickly hi mix and so forth so
we're very very excited about 15 and and
particularly the f-150 one of the things
that you do by shaving 700 pounds off
this truck making a lot of it with
aluminum is increase the fuel efficiency
of the vehicle a lot of people have
wondered if low gas prices would reduce
the incentive for American men and women
to go out and buy this new more
fuel-efficient truck how are you seeing
the low gas prices affect your sales
well we don't we haven't seen any impact
in the marketplace yet probably too
early we think probably first quarter we
might start seeing how consumers are
going to behave in the new environment
that we're in although we do expect over
the longer term that oil and gas prices
will go back up but I you know the
important thing around the f-150
f-series the trucks is cost of ownership
so better fuel efficiency and on top of
that even lower you know gas prices
every time you fill it up that's got to
be a positive and historically we have
seen a positive reaction in terms of
segmentation when we've seen gasp
prices go down so what's the wait and
see but that could be a you know a
positive for us as we move into 2015 you
know edmunds.com I'm sure you saw did a
piece where they took a sledgehammer to
an f-150 and then tried to get it
repaired and said that it costs more
than it would repair a normal steel
truck and that that would affect maybe
even insurance rates how do you react or
how are you hearing Ford other Ford
execs react to that that story yeah
unfortunately that's that's not accurate
we know that the insurance rates are
going to be about the same and we've
seen evidence of that from people that
have actually purchased the vehicles and
purchased insurance and unfortunately in
this particular case they went to a
dealer who was not certified it was not
among the 750 dealers or the thousand
independent body shops that we've
certified for repair so the the
information that they provided to
Edmonds was was incorrect we expect the
cost of ownership and the cost of
repairs to be very very competitive on
the the new f-150 and we've designed it
that way so we're quite confident that
let's go over to Europe here because on
the conference call mark fields the CEO
was saying that maybe losses in Europe
will be more than the 250 million
dollars you are projecting back in
September that's because of obviously
the crazy situation in Russia but also I
expect because of the strong dollar
how's that how's that turning out well
it's not so much the strong dollar it's
really more the relationship between the
euro and the ruble because most of what
we ship into Russia to support our
production there is actually coming from
from Europe so it's more that
relationship than it is the dollar the
progress we've made on the
transformation plan in Western Europe
you know the traditional part of our of
our market there is actually gone very
very well when we put our plan together
for Europe we had expected Russia to to
be a growing market and significant
contributor to the business as as it
grew and we participated in that but the
clearly things have changed pretty
dramatically over the last year and 2015
and Russia is looking very difficult so
that's the that's the impact that we
really talked about today when we we
talked about the guidance for Europe for
15 Bob does the strong dollar though I
mean I realize you produce most of the
product you sell in Europe in
europe and obviously you know japanese
carmakers produce a lot of cars they
sell here in the US here in the US and
so a lot of the the currency fluctuation
effects may have may be negated on the
other hand doesn't it give them a
competitive advantage the European and
Japanese carmakers because they can
afford to take a margin loss when
they're selling vehicles here in the US
yeah you're spot on we don't see as we
look across our entire global business
we don't see the strong dollar net net
having a material impact in terms of
exchange rate impact itself but the big
the big factor where that were most
concerned about is the competitive
advantage it gives particularly the
Japanese and so what you said is exactly
what we're concerned about and one of
the reasons why in the trans-pacific
partnership trade agreement that's under
discussions we're really insisting on
having very strict enforceable currency
rules as part of that all right bob
thanks so much for your time really
appreciate it we got to show the new
raptor didn't get to ask about the gt350
but i will next time you're on have a
great day ok